this is like a beautiful area yeah let
me just get a picture of you like right
here it'll work great I look around
right all right here we go okay this is
great
what is sorry I'm not down there Matt
give me a smile Matt Matt look over here
the bacteria looks amazing why are you
doing standing you turn a twirl for me
twirl twirl um excuse me you can't come
in here every night wearing heels let me
see your Apple watch yeah I love it so
nice show me though do a little walk
whoa the fit on that wrist oh thank you
so I got the promotion I'm gonna be
working more hours I'm so excited
Oh more hours how are you gonna balance
all that who's gonna watch your kids my
kids pull my husband's on it he's a
stay-at-home dad cool you guys are so
progressive not you look amazing thank
you you get so fit to fit into this what
working whatever it is it's working
Hey yeah how'd you work that Terry of it
yeah we raised a bunch of money Wow
is that what you were wearing
oh wow well let's get a look let's let's
get a 360 yeah look at that fabric
hey how long did it take you to get
ready today what how long did it take
you to get ready America is dying to
know
no I don't you just drove me here I
would know about that right now I mean
I'm the cat but I live alone
Oh woohoo are it better I'm done